the winner of the tailor the JG Taylor
[ __ ] award at the National Baseball
Hall of Fame and Museum joining us with
the latest on what's going on in
baseball he is Jason stark how are you
Jason I'm great how are you you know
what do you have a camera trained on my
notes so you already know the questions
coming okay very good that's a very Lou
now answer I must say it sounds like
they're caught red-handed here Jason
this is what happened in 2017 correct
yeah you know the reporting in this
piece in the athletic by Ken Rosenthal
and Evan Drella is so good and so
thorough rich I mean Mike fiers who used
to pitch for that team is quoted on the
record telling us exactly what they did
and how they did it and you know since
this story broke in the last 24 hours
I've heard from players coaches Scouts
all echoing the reporting in this story
saying that they always knew something
like this was happening they just didn't
know why and you know you know a lot of
people in the game who are cheering on
this just because it's the Astros I
think it's safe to say the other 29
teams or most of them are not fans
they've always looked at the Astros as a
team that would push the envelope just
about anywhere to gain an edge and hey
the conspiracy theories I've heard about
them over the last few years are
unbelievable I'll tell you one that
actually wrote at one point you know
these two had that big towels hill at
the center-field minute level Vail and
what did they put in it they built a
sports bar what are you having a sports
bar
giant video screens in centerfield who's
sitting there right underneath the video
screens their bullpen and so like
everything that they do has raised
suspicions and now it's just all laid
out in meticulous fashion well it's it's
here's the thing that's really jarring
about it is it's blatant it
systemic it's well thought out it's well
executed based on some of the videos
that we are seeing on social media that
certainly back up the knowledge of an
off-speed pitch coming associated with a
bang that you do hear picked up on a
camera even Danny Farquhar who's quoted
in this a pitcher for the White Sox
basically called his catcher out saying
that he was on to the fact that they
were on to something so the question is
here Jason is worried assuming they stop
doing it and they didn't do it over the
last two years at all I don't know that
we can assume anything I mean that video
that you referenced on the John Boy yes
Twitter feed is incredible people who
haven't watched it need to watch it just
documented also clearly and I think like
baseball has taken steps in 2019 going
into this season to try to control this
you know they've had people monitoring
the video room we playroom they it
stipulated that the video feeds to those
rooms
you're still on tape the way but when
I've asked people in the game and that
take care of it they laugh they said
well what about the the video room that
the hitters go and visit in between the
bathroom you would back theirs they have
a live feed you know it's not as easy
now but baseball can't monitor every
inch they can't monitor the dug it out
they can't my video rooms you know
there's rumors that there are people in
the stands remember in the 2018 LCS the
Red Sox caught one I don't know exactly
what they're still doing I just know you
know I've covered almost every
postseason game that they played over
the last two years I've seen them all
great pitchers in a way that really made
me wonder what they knew Jason Stark
here on the Rich Eisen show if this
happened in the NFL and with the
Patriots we know
would be blamed for it now who is the
who is the driving force behind all this
is it AJ Hinch Jason that's one that I
you know it's difficult to pinpoint I
would say that the suspicion is that it
starts above him that it did it's being
it's being fueled above him and they're
in a really interesting situation here
rich because and we don't need to relive
what happened during the postseason when
Brandon Todman who was Jeff Munoz number
one assistant was overheard saying some
stuff to some female reporters that got
him fired yeah well now maybe league
baseball and already scheduled a meeting
with Brandon to ask him about that
incident now it's clear and it's clear
in the story of the athletic that they
intend to ask him about this to asking
exactly what he knew and what's going on
and I mean he he may not have held the
smoking gun but I think there's a good
chance he saw it smoking and I don't
know what tails he would could tell but
there's a lot of information that could
be revealed here very shortly
well I mean if with Hinch it would be a
say it ain't so situation for me because
he's done everything the right way
everything from and from my seat the
pushing buttons obviously in the game
and keeping Verlander in old-school in
games and then obviously with the
hurricane and the way he handled that
situation in Houston and everything you
know the media the way that he's you
know he's called in the show many times
and I've enjoyed our conversations that
would just be a bummer and it's tough to
wonder how how he wouldn't know any of
this if the players are clearly a tune
into a bang means off-speed pitch
silence means hard stuff system I mean
wouldn't everybody have to know this
you would think you know I'm with you AJ
Hinch is one of my favorite people in
the game I've often said that it you
know I just hire one manager after I
bought a team I think I would hire him
and I really I've known AJ since he's a
player I really admire them
I joined being around them I enjoy being
around their players but you know we've
reached a stage now where I think people
are going to question everything because
how could you not question it it just
it's just tricky because their team is
so good like that's a great team we
shouldn't question the talent but we're
gonna question everything else and know
you you raised the Patriots it's so some
other Patriots isn't it it's so someone
Spygate how do you look at Spygate does
it tarnish everything the Patriots have
done for you well the difference is
Jason would Spygate again that what the
Patriots did with with that although I
know a ram or two that think that the
Patriots were spying on their practices
prior to the Super Bowl that Brady and
Belichick won for the first time but
that is thoroughly unsubstantiated that
is just belief as opposed to proof the
Spygate stuff though was not actionable
material that was being accrued for in
the moment you could not take the video
of stealing their signs and be able to
communicate it to if you will Tom Brady
through head said before snap you just
couldn't do that or into the headset of
a defender before a snap you just
couldn't do that sort of thing it was
not possible it was to just guess get a
library to prepare for the next time
that they play or maybe for the second
half I mean this stuff is like okay the
pitch you're about to see is this and
you could somehow it actually worked
also though you could see how sometimes
it didn't matter because it's so damn
tough to hit a baseball that you look at
the the Astros record that year they
were better on the road than they were
at home and the game in which Danny far
coarseness
sniffed it all out they lost to Farkle
Farquhar act they only got one run in
that game so I guess it does lead to the
question of what does it mean what is it
what does it all mean when it comes down
to it just I guess on in theory in
spirit it's dreadful but did it actually
mean anything when we're talking about
the astros 2017 championship that's a
really difficult thing to quantify I
don't think there's any doubt that this
is something that they've used and has
had an impact in certain games certain
situations some of those really big
games and really big moments but how
much is it meant in terms of who wanted
lost that's really difficult to say
because you know I think we can't lose
sight of this they're not the only team
doing this we know that we know that
there are other teams that are doing
similar stuff and you don't know if the
teams that they were playing we're doing
the same stuff and there were moments
and games would they had that advantage
too we just know that we've reached this
stage of paranoia in the sport that
baseball has to figure out a way to
address because you know it's
fascinating to watch and fascinating to
contemplate but I don't think it's
adding to the entertainment level of a
game as teens are constantly trying to
change signs and Catterick sometimes
against what's coming in the blogger's
the backstop and stuff you see is
totally result of sign stealing and
paranoia and all the stuff that teams
think is happening whether it is or not
well last question for you on this and
then I got one more hot stove before I
let you go Jason stark here on the Rich
Eisen show so you say other they're not
the only team doing it and also it's so
difficult for Major League Baseball to
police it in real time where there are
rooms anywhere
in the bowels of any stadium where
videos can be seen you know players just
leave the dugout for a second they go
and they see something or you mention
how there are television screens and
centerfield located
sports bars now I mean there's so
difficult to police it but what baseball
can do is try and prevent it from
happening because of a punishment that
they deliver how severe will this
punishment be for the Astros based on
what we can know right now Jason start
really difficult to say because there is
not a lot of precedent for this I mean
the only precedent in recent years is
the Yankees catching the Red Sox
coaching staff wearing those Apple
watches a couple years back and that was
just a funny you know so how different
is this than that
how much more pervasive is this and that
is this than that can't answer those
questions yet it looks to be more
pervasive but this is this is going to
be a really difficult one for Rob
Manfred or whoever doles out this
function to short out because there
there really is no precedent for
anything like this at this level of
technology that I know well I mean we
saw a lifetime ban handed out to the
all-time hit king because they thought
that he might have he might have
influenced the outcome of a game based
on on who he bet on or against how is
this not some sort of cheating that it
couldn't where there's visual evidence
of it affecting an at-bat I mean we see
it on Twitter right now Jason you know
it's clearly against the rules and not
quite in the way that what Pete Rose did
over years and years was against the you
know the ultimate cardinal rule but
there's no doubt that Rob Manfred needs
to make a statement because there are
other teams doing this and we you know
they have to find a way to if not stop
it strongly discourage it I know my
friend Joel Sherman wrote a column
saying it's time to turn
all the technology all the video
monitors all of it all over the ballpark
and time to keep players from the
heading up into the clubhouse between it
bats between innings and I don't know if
that's doable but this is serious and
the whole world's watching and the whole
world would be paying great attention to
whatever Rob Manfred desert last one for
you here oh I got two more coal or
Verlander tonight scion call overlander
who'd you vote for
did you can you say you know what I I
did not have a vote okay I wrote a
column about it and I like to me this is
basically a tie but if I had to pick one
I think I would lean toward Justin
Verlander and the case would be this I
had a historic year his whip for the
year is was zero point eight zero and
that's insane way less a base runner per
inning since 1900s these are the only
pitchers who will last you have
baserunners in that it was Pedro in 2000
and there was Walter Johnson in 1913 but
Gerrit Cole had the highest strikeout
rate for any starting pitching ever so
he was a start to I I think
Verlander wins but I had no idea crazy
all right now last one for you why are
guys like Mookie Betts and Lindor
supposedly on the block here well what
is happening with Major League Baseball
where stud players who are maybe maybe
and it appears to be with these guys
generationally talented being available
how does that happen
yeah it's a shame but it's not quite
identical situations now in Mookie's
case the Red Sox can't afford him they
would love to keep them but they haven't
been able to assign them to anything he
has not agreed to
any any sort of extension and has made
it clear then he wants to test the
market and know they're in a situation
now where all right all of a sudden
ownership is dictating we want
get under the luxury tax threshold they
bring in a guy from the outside from
Tampa Bay in hind bloom to run the show
he's not there to keep the band together
it's hard to imagine he's not going to
aggressively explore this inland doors
case the Indians are one of the most
revenue challenge teams in the sport
they've got a star player who's two
years away from free agency and just
they don't feel like their economic
model they can afford to keep that
player and so they're gonna do what they
sadly done so many times and that is
take a guy like this and move them I
don't know it'll be this winter but it's
going to be sometime and what a shame
and what happens first Super Bowl 54 or
coal signs somewhere I got super bald
man the only you know a chance to
co-sign it before the halftime of the
Super Bowl is if the Angels get a signal
that he really wants to be there
and honey Moreno says all right let's
just get it done and they swoop in and
offer him exactly what he wants but let
me add to that and never happen so we'll
see pitbull perform before we see Clovis
I'm very good good chat and Jason you
got it you got it you got it
Jason stark right back at you at Jason
St on Twitter and Instagram for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app